previously on Latins wrath oh this is  devastating  Oh Oh No everything is gone oh [ __ ]  everything is gone I'm so sorry mark  you're such hey our chests are still  over there hey I'm going over the chests  I'm so sorry  it's not my fault that your boyfriend is  completely hands everyone is just  jealous because Latin has such a great  boyfriend that is don't be like I'm  gonna die  [Laughter]  hey healed me hey that'll last all of a  second Latin did I ever mention now how  older girl wanna bang her boyfriend okay  all right do you like totally legitimate  you're I'm not saying anything I am  officially shutting up  anyway jaqen in the shadow of the penis  wait what kind of mary did wait kid wait  legit Mary Mary yeah I got I got the  ring on my penis or